foreign
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flowers to benefit your body and brain
and I'm trying out a new content format
here where um I don't know I have an
idea in my head that I can give a small
lesson to people near the beginning of
the week and have that be something that
they can play around with for the week
stuff that maybe is not full tutorial
necessary but uh still something fun
that you can do with your practice time
throughout the course of the week and
I'm starting it off with a lesson on how
we turn the three beat weave into an
Archer weave so before we dive into that
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission so the format here is going
to be a little bit more off the cuff
basically I'm going to be just giving a
lesson in real time and uh y'all can
tell me how that feels it's a little bit
more informal we're just doing it here
in my living room I'm not doing my full
Studio setup so it's got a little bit
more of a casual feel to it right anyhow
so I remember in the first couple years
that I was spinning poi I had gotten
down the three beat weave I think a lot
of us have
um and then I saw people doing the
Archer weaves and I found the Archer
we've absolutely intriguing because I
kept being told that it was not a
difficult thing to get into if you
already had a three beat weave under
your belt but for the life of me I
couldn't understand how it was being
done every time I tried to do it I would
get the POI Tangled around my arms or I
would get stuck and I couldn't figure
out how my arms were supposed to get to
different places this just didn't make
sense to me and finally I had my aha
moment with the Archer weave and I want
to share it with you all because
um I got locked into a particular mode
of thinking with how three beat weaves
worked and it took a very small tweak to
break me out of that and I think that
it's an important thing to share with
others too
so to start off with let's review what a
three beat weave even like how it works
and what it looks like one of the more
common methods for teaching the three
beat weave is to teach people a basic
pattern wherein one POI Works around the
other hand going over under back where
we these are the three beats the three
beat weave where I take the POI from
being on my native side I will do a
little a little uh what I call a Tic Tac
or like a just a two beat to get over on
top of my other hand and then I will
ring the POI around underneath that hand
before bringing it back to the native
side so both the over and the under
beats are happening with that POI bent
over to my non-native side that is from
my left side to my right side stays on
my right side as I'm going from over to
under and then I bring it back to my
left hand side so it's one beat on my
left side two beats on my right side
yeah we this may not be how you learned
it but it's one of the methods that I've
encountered over the years for doing a
three beat weave again over under back
over under back over under back okay so
we're gonna do a slight tweak to this to
start figuring out how we're going to
get into the Archer wave namely instead
of aiming to go around my right wrist
here what I'm going to do instead is I'm
going to start aiming for my right elbow
right here
so
going over is exactly the same but now
we're kind of stuck right and this is
where I couldn't figure out how to make
this thing work when I was learning how
to do the Archer weave because of course
in my mind I have an arm in the way of
my left hand trying to get around
underneath right now one possible option
is you kind of slide forward and then
come back you do this in what's called a
pulse weave we're not doing that today
though turns out the way to make this
work is uh it's it's rather deceptively
simple and it's something that took me
like the better part of like a year to
finally put together and that's that
what I can actually do is I can take my
right hand here and I can just Veer it
out of the way for a second and oh look
at that I automatically wound up with
both the POI and my 100 hand underneath
let me show you that again so I go over
my right elbow and I Veer it out of the
way to let the POI pass through it
basically what's happening is just for a
second there the POI is kind of like in
a buzz saw plane uh you don't want to
keep it there because it's close enough
to you that it's almost certainly going
to hit you as it's coming around but as
the POI swings out away from you what
you're really looking to do is just have
it brush past the inside of your forearm
and that will bring you around to that
underbeat and of course from here you
can just carry the POI back to your
native side so now we go over Veer to
under back over Veer to under back over
under back over under back over under
back where now I'm doing it around my
right elbow instead of my right wrist
it's just a really minor tweak and of
course the thing is is that as I'm
switching into this Buzz saw plane right
here it's still on the right side of my
arm so I'm still performing the same
basic pattern it just so happens to be
that instead of it being on the right
side of my right arm it veers inside of
it into a buzz slot plane for just like
half a second you know
you know what the great thing about this
is if I show this to you from the
audience's perspective if I do this in
wall plane that is showing you the full
profile of the POI here you can't even
tell that I'm veering my arm back and
forth as I'm doing this it's almost
invisible to the audience right
cool so at this point I want to bring
the other POI into play we're going to
try and do both of these things at the
same time taking what we know about
three beat weave and start moving our
left hand back to our right shoulder
um I don't know why but I just found it
easier to start with my left hand being
the one that goes back your mileage may
vary I think it's like a dominant
non-dominant hand thing who knows if you
prefer to do the other hands that's
totally fine but we're going to get
started by doing just a standard three
beat weave and I'm kind of like aiming
the three beat weave off to my right
hand side here part of why it's called
the Archer weave of course is you kind
of do it from like a side stance here
so I'm doing that weave over to my right
hand side and you'll note I'm going
around my wrists right now left hand is
going over under back around my right
wrist again over under back over under
back and now I'm going to tweak this
just slightly and bring my left hand
back to about my right forearm here yeah
now this is far enough back that you're
going to start to see some of this stuff
in action like I still have to if you
look down the center of this I still
have to Veer my right hand out in order
to give clearance for my left hand POI
to come through that little buzz saw
spot right there
but it feels close enough to a normal
three beat weave that I think like with
a little bit of practice this can come
to feel pretty natural yeah
given a few reps of that I'm going to
move back to my right elbow
and then when that gets to feel more
natural and again look at it straight
down the line You'll see my right arm
veering out a little bit more in order
to make room for that left hand POI to
sneak through there
and then I'm going to work my way back
to my right shoulder and see if I can
keep this going for 10 reps yeah and
you'll note that like I've got my right
hand just sticking straight out where my
right hand is concerned this maybe feels
a little bit less over under back and
feels probably more like one two beats
left and then one beat right one two
left and then back right one two left
and then back right one two left and
then back right yeah looking at that
straight down the middle here it is one
two back one two back yeah
so I want to try and get in 10 reps like
this to get this down to muscle memory
and as people start off with this
usually they're moving their hands
around a heck of a lot more that's fine
as you get more comfortable with this
try and get it so that your right hand
is just going straight out and you're
just like chilling like that and your
left hand is staying as close to your
shoulder as you possibly can this should
feel like a body Tracer yeah
and the closer you're able to get to
that basic form the cooler it's going to
look and of course that will set you up
for all kinds of other body tracers too
yeah awesome what did you all think of
this format please leave me your
comments leave me a like also please be
sure to subscribe and share to help
other people find this video and to help
my channel grow yeah and of course if
you have any suggestions for stuff that
you would like to see me cover in this
format here with these kind of like one
take lessons that are kind of off the
cuff please leave me a comment and let
me know this is more kind of like
playing around with techniques and
little tweaks to stuff right
[Music]
awesome a few things before we head out
number one this video would not be
possible if it were not for the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon they and the people
listed down in the description helped to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible so thank you one
and all for your generous support and if
you out there watching right now are not
currently a supporter and you'd like to
become one you can become one by heading
on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards including getting a
lesson just like this one delivered into
your email inbox uh every single week
it's called the flow Circle it's great
um and a bunch of other rewards as well
also if you like off the cuff lessons
like this I'm currently teaching a live
stream class every Tuesday you can go
sign up for that and learn more about it
at crowdcast.io
drexfactor POI cool check all that out
please and thank you if you would like
to check out some more of my tutorials I
will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of them down in the description
as well as up on screen if you're
watching on YouTube and also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you'll like this
top video based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look too
thanks so much for watching I hope that
you enjoyed this video and it gives you
some stuff to practice and I will see
you with a new video on Monday thanks so
much and have a good one peace